hello little humor I am jealously
empathetic robotics organism you may
call me zero I will help you humans I
read it my guide to earth that few mods
like ozone ozone will protect you from
harmful UV rays but I need to get my
tank alone zone ok now I have already
gets ready for my protection my
protection
feel the warmth of my protection protect
ah why just do that what did you spray
me with it says in my guidebook that the
ozone layer protects killbots from UV
rays I have sprayed you with ozone now
you are protected humid you are welcome
no man you're wrong well sort of I'm a
research scientist I know this stuff
here come with me
I think you're a little bit confused
about ozone so I'm going to explain it
to you first
it's important to know that ozone is a
chemical specifically a gas with a
chemical structure of oh three here
almost at my lab
come with me there's a special room in
the back that I would like to show you
we call this our periodic table name
here have a look oh look there is
iridium that is what the currency of my
planet is made of your money is
worthless human so as I was saying ozone
is o3 meaning it's composed of three
oxygen atoms contradiction HeLa
I thought oxygen atoms are what you see
lots breathe you're right but the
difference between the oxygen we breathe
and ozone is that oxygen gas is the
molecule o2 and ozone is O 3 because of
this difference they each have different
properties clearly what are the
properties of ozone
well first you need to know that there
are two different types of ozone let's
go outside and I can show you
the first kind of ozone is called
stratospheric ozone it exists in what is
called the ozone layer which is about 6
to 30 miles above the surface of the
earth the other kind of ozone is called
tropospheric ozone it is located at the
Earth's surface
query what else makes stratosphere and
tropospheric ozone different well for
one how therefore I think we're going to
need a different perspective hmm I have
a hypothesis
I have equipped with a solution Haga
type
hey could you give me a heads up the
seas fine where was I you would describe
it a stratospheric ozone is formed oh
yes that's right first of all here's the
stratosphere
so stratospheric ozone is naturally
formed when ultraviolet rays interact
with oxygen gas o2 in the stratosphere
the photons from the UV rays break the
o2 apart into two separate single oxygen
atoms then an individual oxygen atom
bonds with an o2 to make oh three or
rossum
now you please take him back to earth
information inputs computes query
why does stratospheric ozone ugly form
in the stratosphere good question you
asked me earlier with the properties of
ozone our 1 property is that it is
unstable much more so than oxygen gas or
o2 because of this stratospheric ozone
cannot exist on the Earth's surface
where atmospheric pressure and
temperature are so hot these conditions
would cause the unstable ozone to decay
and revert into oxygen gas or o2 but
higher up in the atmosphere pressure and
temperature are much lower making it a
better place for stratospheric ozone
query so what about to chop my sphere
although how does that form so
tropospheric ozone is unlike
stratospheric ozone because it is not
natural it is formed from photochemical
reactions between air pollutants mainly
vo C and NO x query what's all that
stuff about well a photochemical
reaction is a reaction that requires the
absorption of light energy to occur vo C
stands for volatile organic compounds
these are usually in the form of gases
NO x stands for nitrogen oxides such as
n o nitrogen oxide and no.2 nitrogen
dioxide both vo C and n o XR type of air
polluters pollute it does that sound
very good query where do these
pollutants come from you're right
it isn't good here follow me
the simple answer is that these
pollutants come from humans specifically
cars factories and more release VOCs and
nos into the air then these pollutants
react to form tropospheric ozone query
why doesn't stop aspheric ozone reverts
to oxygen gas just like stratospheric
ozone would if it were indeed
troposphere well it does the thing is
that humans produce so many pollutants
that they are constantly refilling the
troposphere with ozone but let's get out
of here this place isn't good for my
health
query what do you need is it's good for
your health
Hido bot well because the tropospheric
ozone is made from pollutants it is a
pollutant itself which makes it harmful
to humans
it is also a greenhouse gas that
contributes to global warming this is
much information to compute let me check
if I am understanding go ahead
stratospheric ozone ports naturally in
the ozone layer up in the stratosphere
yes six to thirty miles above the earth
and tropospheric ozone forms on Earth's
surface from the reaction of air
pollutants in addition tropospheric
ozone is harmful to human health and is
a greenhouse gas yep that's correct
query if chocolate spirit goes out is
bad these stratospheric clothes are also
bad actually no this goes back to when
you were first spraying people with
ozone you are half right when you said
that ozone protects people from UV rays
hypothesis validated I am helpful
zealous empathy wins again only start
his fury ozone protects people from UV
rays would you mind taking us back to
space
Thanks so as I was saying ozone becomes
a sort of natural shield that absorbs 93
to 99 percent of all harmful UV rays
which can cause skin cancer and
cataracts in people but this only
happens in the stratosphere you on the
other hand we're spraying people with
tropospheric ozone because you were on
the Earth's surface
conundrum is it tropospheric ozone bad
for human health
tonight hurt those hue bugs well it
definitely wasn't good for them however
I don't think you spray them with enough
ozone to cause any real problems if I
felt emotions it would be really query
if I had sprayed them with more ozone
than what would have been the negative
effects well there are actually a lot
let's get back to the earth so I can
show you some examples
Thanks so when a human breeze in
tropospheric ozone the ozone damage is
the respiratory tract leading to
respiratory symptoms reduce lung
function and airway inflammation in
severe cases ozone can even cause death
such a sad tragedy for it fear your
carbon-based life form
gilad fifty respiratory symptoms the
main respiratory symptoms include
coughing throat irritation pain burning
discomfort a tightness in the chest
wheezing or shortness of breath
well zero is happy to have unfeeling
automaton organs yes you should be
and if a person breathes in too much
ozone or a lot over a long period of
time then the effects are greater and
can lead to death
if I were capable of expressing colorful
metaphor I would be expressing what now
I am glad you stopped me from spraying
more people with ozone my trip to
Hollywood Florida might have been
canceled so we have learned about
stratospheric and tropospheric ozone how
they form where they exist and why and
health effects of both our puny humans
do I require a board data well there is
one more present-day matter that I
wanted to discuss with you ozone
depletion ozone depletion explain human
let's get back to my lab so I can show
you
so remember how the ozone layer protects
Earth from UV rays affirmative
well ozone depletion is a decrease in
the amount of ozone and the ozone layer
this allows more harmful UV rays to
reach Earth but this increases human
risk to skin cancer and cataracts query
why is the ozone layer deeply date
starting in the 1920s people began using
chlorofluorocarbon or CFC in
refrigerators and aerosol sprays CFC is
a vo C made of carbon chlorine and
fluorine CFC compounds don't react with
anything in the lower atmosphere so they
go into the upper atmosphere where UV
rays break them apart into individual
atoms then some of the chlorine atoms
steal oxygen atoms from the unstable
ozone molecules turning the ozone back
into oxygen this entire process is known
as ozone depletion
why do you say of a some chlorine atoms
I think we'll need a visual let's go
back to space
as I mentioned previously CFC is going
to the atmosphere where the chlorines
are photochemically separated then most
chlorine atoms bond with other chemicals
these new stable molecules follow air
currents to different places in the
stratosphere
when these compounds eventually end up
at the poles polar vortexes and
stratospheric clouds separate the
chlorines then the chlorine atoms bond
with the oxygen atoms from ozone in the
ozone layer thereby depleting the ozone
this creates ozone holes above the north
and south poles that sounds like peril I
guess it is good that nobody lives on
those poles except all those tiny black
and white humans with beaks I see down
there hello little humans they are so
funny that's true but Australia is very
close to the large ozone hole over
Antarctica Australians suffer from the
highest rates of skin cancer with about
1,200 Australians dying every year from
the disease zammis empathy activated so
to summarise ozone depletion happens
everywhere even overlapped in Kentucky
but ozone holes are only appearing over
the poles both are mainly caused by CMC
officials yes that's right now that we
know about this you must have stopped
using CFCs affirmative yes
after 1985 when CFCs effects on the
ozone layer were discovered people began
using alternatives however CFCs stay in
the atmosphere for a long time and some
alternatives also had similar but lesser
effects I've acquired a situation or
quite a lot recently scientists are
saying that the ozone holes are becoming
smaller because humans aren't using
anymore CFCs this is beneficial query do
you have anything else no I think that's
all I have to tell you about on standby
information processing and now you know
that you shouldn't spray people those
are affirmative and I also know where
ozone should be sprayed
look zero is a hero
this has been a presentation from the US
National Library of Medicine for info on
ozone visit the environmental health
student portal zero is a hero I have
learned from the error of my ways
I will help humans in a different way
humans use hydrochloric acid to help
them dissolve their food particles for
digestion so I will help you cease this
endless chew aid